hi and welcome to episode number 20 of
the quickly Google club back on podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm sure with my
colleague mark Mendel hey Mark hey
France sku doing pretty good pretty good
very excited about the topic today even
though it's not my favorite topic so
we're not talking about go it's very
true we're gonna be talking about node
and we have a script yeah we're gonna be
talking nodejs only a cloud yep yeah we
got actually just in back with a product
manager for Google cloud platform that
specializes among all the things on ojs
so we're gonna have him talking about
why you should use and I'm gonna say you
should use like why you could use kno
jes and google app yeah i would say like
if no Jess and javascript is your your
product of choice if it's your thing if
it would have made your choice we have a
lot of really cool stuff that we going
to talk about analytical partnerships
and yeah so it's having fun stuff and
then at the end of the at the end of the
episode we're going to be talking a
little bit about a quest of the week on
BigTable yeah very cool but before that
let's talk a little bit about the cool
thing of the week yeah we had a couple
of really nice announcements about cloud
datastore actually that's a product
that's been around for quite a long line
long while but it's getting some love
which I'm like I'm very happy to see
yeah it's it's been there probably it's
one of the oldest solutions that we have
it came with Google App Engine i'm
assuming seemed so too yeah pre old yeah
still very good yeah so if you aren't
familiar with a data storage it's our
new sequel data store the cool thing
about it though is it doesn't really
matter how much data you put inside it
the read and write time stay the same
and it shards and replicates for you
which is pretty awesome it's very very
very powerful yeah it works very well
with a pension basically it's they both
scale from 0 to 0 whatever you want yeah
very very well it scales on traffic
scales on data you don't have to do
anything it's completely managed so very
very sweet project to use but one of
things I like to see ISM the pricing
structure for data store before was
let's just say it was complicated it was
yeah complex complex it was fun it would
have been really difficult to kind of
work out exactly what you need to do up
front it was it wasn't yeah it was
tricky it was definitely tricky um well
we fix that we fixed it we just fixed it
yeah well not us but yeah so how does it
work now so now it's far far simpler
simply put if you are going to write
something it is simply based on that
right for that entity you no longer have
to worry about indexes or anything like
that reads are the same the cost is per
entity and deletes are exactly the same
in that it's just power entities you'll
be charged for a delete for a single
delete operation per entity and we've
got flat rates for all of those now so
cool for you to work out exactly what
those sort of you know costs are going
to be upfront much much easier very nice
and that also translates into a most use
cases you're going to end up paying less
yeah which is great which is great you
don't have to worry as much about your
indexes like yeah cost savings great
makes life a lot easier if your
developers you don't have to like micro
like manage all of these things so that
you can keep your costs down we want to
make that happy in yeah just write the
code that you should your thing you
should ride and then everything should
just work with and adapt to the use case
you're doing absolutely now we also have
one other thing for data store as well
do we we do so if you're interacting
with data store save particularly
outside of F engine we really some new
API is to make that a little bit faster
very nice how is that a little bit
faster how did we make that how did we
do it so we have a new v 1 beta 3
version of the datastore API the real
agencies on that we will have links to
the graphs in the show notes but
significant performance improvements is
the exact quote I'm looking at the red
line is much shorter than the blue line
of the graphs which I think's it better
which is good so not only we're trying
to make things simpler for you cheaper
for you but also faster for you as well
if if that's what you're looking for
very cool and something that I really
like is that that also includes so
there's a JSON API but there's also
protocol buffers on grp see it had to be
there yeah we wanted to be faster so of
course so yeah if you if you have some
little process running somewhere where
you want to have something working
really fast to store data
grp see over data store and that's
pretty much it awesome very cool so why
don't we go to our main content for
today and let's go talk with Justin
sounds great let's do that thanks so
much to Justin Beckwith for joining us
for this wonderful evening today Justin
how you doing I'm doing fantastic how
are you guys doing pretty good we're
great yep so for those haven't met you
haven't had the chance to be in the
presence of your very effervescent
personality um why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself what you do
here at Google that's like a good stuff
absolutely so my name is Justin Beckwith
I'm a product manager here at google and
primarily I have the chance to work on
the developer experience for Google App
Engine and it's a really fun gig I get
to dig deep into technologies deep into
nodejs PHP Python Ruby you know just
about anything they get help influence
what it's like for developers to walk up
to our platform and use it hopefully
making it a little bit easier cool now I
believe you have a bit of a focus on
nodejs is that correct yeah it's been
it's been a huge huge couple of months
for us on nodejs we just shipped the
beta of the nodejs runtime on App Engine
so I've been doing a lot a lot of
JavaScript these days whole load of
JavaScript excellent excellent okay so I
guess the first question I asked is like
why why nodejs like we seem to be doing
a lot of work there it seems to be
obviously you finding it quite important
like what's the reasoning there what are
we doing yeah so there are a lot of
great reasons to use nodejs I think the
big thing that first attracted me to the
platform and the the first development
team I was on that started using it it
was about taking advantage of a single
language both for our front-end in our
back-end code so we'd spent years and
years and years building up this
building up a lot of muscle on using
javascript for front-end web
applications and you know all of a
sudden you'd go to the back and you had
to go completely different language
different package manager different
build system different libraries the
whole thing I think the big beauty of
nodejs is that you learn one language
one ecosystem you know NPM is getting
huge and now I can use those skills
front-end back-end you know services web
applications API
is you I doesn't matter it works the
whole way across the stack for me I
think that's the most attractive quality
of node yeah that sounds very good also
so either I don't do not tell yes but
I'm very happy that Google is coming a
little bit more to the community of not
jas because there's actually a lot of
people outside that are doing it so it's
a little bit following the philosophy of
go where the developers are developers
are doing a low note so that's great the
next question is about so yeah okay so
why why Google like no jss is very cool
there's a lot of people that are doing
it but what is the relationship between
Google and no tas yes we have a bit of
an interesting history here actually no
Jas started happening around I want to
say it was 2009 want started getting
built and it's built on top of v8
JavaScript execution engine that's part
of Google Chrome so we spend all of
these years building up all this
expertise on optimizing JavaScript
making it run as fast as humanly
possible on in web browsers and then a
group of folks over a joint started
building and making it fast for running
on the server side as well and for a
couple of years you know here at Google
we have a set of languages that we focus
on and JavaScript on the server side
traditionally hasn't been one of them
and so that effort kind of went on in
parallel and really I think I think over
the last few years especially this year
as jazz nodejs has gotten closer to
being more viable for enterprise
application development we're starting
it a little bit more involved right we
sort of sat aside and let this thing
develop on its own and now we're trying
to dig in and we're trying to be a help
to the community I think that you're
starting to see a lot more large
corporations take a bet on nodejs big
companies there's a LTS support model
now in place so you know that with the
latest versions you're going to get 18
months of backward compatibility and
security patches you know kind of in my
mind I think the big thing that's
shifted is it's starting to get real I
think at first it was great if you were
building small time web applications
startups you need to do something
quickly it was a popular choice but now
we can use this to build real web
applications it's actually harder to
find companies that aren't using node at
this stage if they're doing web
development cool so all right so
obviously yet what que no no and that's
great but what is what is the developer
experience look like right now for
wanting to use node on Google cloud
platform like
what products is it like so work with or
what is that that flow look like if I'm
going to sit down and be like I want to
write note now sure so there there a
couple of options there the the one that
almost everyone is used to if you want
to set up a virtual machine and just
bring your code and set up nodejs and
run it of course that's going to work
same as it would any other cloud
provider I think the things that make
running node.js and Google Cloud
interesting unique and useful are both
through google container engine which is
the hosted version of Coober Nettie's
for running docker containers at scale
and then of course App Engine so i'll
start with App Engine then we can talk a
little bit about Cooper Nettie's with
App Engine it's just sort of the ideas
you show up you bring your code and we
run it for you we scale it you push it
to us and we sort of take care of the
rest and if you want to dig in and
customize it at the end of the day all
we're really doing is running docker
containers for you so you if you want to
go customize the image install something
that you want on top of the operating
system something like imagemagick ffmpeg
that sort of thing you can just sort of
take over and define what the runtime is
going to look like but at the end of the
day the idea is you bring the code we
run it so do we like I mean obviously we
sound like we said we release like beta
support for nodejs like what does that
actually mean you said we can just take
the code and run it what is what does
that actually end up looking like sure
so when you come to the platform after
you do the sign up you use the cloud SDK
you can run you build your web
application have inside a directory from
G cloud app deploy and then after that
you're going to get a website running on
a nap spot domain so you'd get you know
my application appspot com and that's
going to scale up to you know I think by
default somewhere between two and twenty
instances running on running on our
platform but really what the beta was
about was just kind of signifying that
all the pieces that come to building a
node.js application it actually goes
beyond what's in App Engine and I think
kind of all those pieces are falling
into place so that's the docker image
that we use to run your app that's now
open source on github nodejs docker and
we publish that out to G cRIO we have
the g-cloud npm module is actually a
really important piece of this so this
is the npm module that provides access
to all of the api's and services things
like bigquery BigTable cloud vision
api we're starting to work on the speech
API all this cool stuff we got to
announced last week or I guess now two
weeks ago at a gcp next and and you know
finally logging integration what is it
like to admit logs from the platform
have an easy way to get access to those
error reporting just sort of all of
these things that sit around the
platform and aren't necessarily running
your code but the things that are really
important when it's time to build your
application monitor it diagnose it all
those sorts of bits so really we've got
we've got all the tools now to build
whatever it is you need to use using all
that up yeah a pieces of our platform
and they may not necessarily been there
before but they were there now yeah
there's something that I wanted to
mention which is so I recently watched
your talk at Jessica next which was
really awesome congratulations on that
thank i really love the demo that
nuclear had that was really cool but one
of the things that you that you showed
was how to basically move from App
Engine 2 to container engine in a very
easy way could you talk a little bit
more about that because I thought it was
very interesting yeah I think that's
actually the best part about App Engine
right now we've you know which started
off as this ecosystem that was a little
bit closed off a little bit you know
vendor specific API is that sort of
thing and it's now reached a point where
really what we're doing is creating an
abstraction that makes it easier to run
docker containers so if you're not
familiar with docker you don't need to
know anything about it you just bring
the code that runs but if you are
familiar with docker and if you have if
you already have a workflow for handling
this kind of work then what you can do
is just run a single command g-cloud
preview app gen config dash dash custom
we can get some resources I'm sure after
this for those are interested in doing
it and it's going to generate the docker
file that we use inside of the runtime
when we run it on top of App Engine so
after that all if you want to run on top
of Coober Nettie's all you have to do is
stand up your cluster run docker build
to build your docker image that's that
has your application code and then you
can deploy it just like you would any
other docker container onto Cooper
Nettie's so it's really flexible up and
down the stack that that is very cold
that also means that you can run the
container directly on your machine right
yeah absolutely that is very nice that's
really cool so
you can basically start with managed VM
sort of just to get you going get you up
and running and then is you need more
flexibility you need to sort of run down
that computers a continuum spectrum
we've sort of talked about before you've
got that option to just pick up and move
that's very powerful I think I think
we're that really shines is where you
want to extend beyond what's in a common
nodejs application so like I mentioned
stuff like imagemagick ffmpeg or let's
say you want to be able to support
multiple languages inside of the same
image at the same time you can
completely take that thing over install
whatever you want on it and then it can
run either an app engine with the
automatic scaling management or over on
kuber Nettie's if you need the control
awesome so I think we should probably
took a little bit about elf in the room
considering we're talking about
JavaScript so pause let's talk about
pause how does how does that strategy
around that sort of fit we keep getting
it at events people look up to a snail
like oh so can I run my passcode on like
Google cloud platform and what does that
look like what do I do yeah this is this
is one of those one of those things we
get a lot especially makes it
interesting the fact that we have
firebase right and firebase is owned by
Google and runs on google cloud now yeah
when you start talking about parse then
everything gets a little bit interesting
but yeah we support obviously we support
both one of the great things that
Facebook did I was actually really
really impressed by this when they
announced that they were going to stop
working on parse as a platform as a
service they rate right out of the gate
announce that they were open sourcing
the components made everything available
to developers sort of and they did that
as an oj s application so if you want to
go run parse server today if you've
already built an app and you've deployed
it to parse and you're looking for a way
to get that off of facebook as they
start to turn the service down they've
made it really easy to take and run that
on other platforms and of course one of
the platforms where that's going to run
it's going to be on Google App Engine so
we have some samples with some
documentation out there we did a blog
post.really getting started with this
thing is pretty simple you just need to
deploy the parser verne ojs application
stand up a MongoDB instance we use [ __ ]
labs I think for our sample when we did
this and then it's pretty easy to
migrate so that's pretty cool I guess
that's almost Testament as well to the
the work that's gone into like making
the beta support for nodejs that you can
take something like the pars open source
framework and be like okay this isn't
too bad we just got
kind of right the documentation to make
this happen yeah it's kind of a funny
story actually when we when we first
read the news that this was happening I
think was about two o'clock and I went
over to Jason dobri who's one of the
platform engineers that works on nodejs
with us he's built a lot of the
documentation a lot of the samples a lot
of the code we have out there on github
and you know we just kind of casually
started talking about what would it take
to get this up and running and I
expected to come back like later that
later in the evening and take a look at
it an hour later I got an email from him
saying that he had the sample already
played a pull request don't get up ready
to go nice so you know I was over the
course of an hour he had that you know
an hour later we had a blog post an hour
after that there was documentation and
you know the evening that it was
announced we had everything up and
running so it's really a testament to
how great the the Facebook guys did and
making this stuff easily portable what
other platform very nice also I guess
it's also a testament to how a pension
is not vendor locked as people tend to
say like you can you can get any code
and just run it there directly that is
very cool yeah it's a big it's a big
change from where we were you know back
in 2008 you notes that engine has been
around for a long time and a lot of
things have changed you know pretty much
any NPM module you want to use for
nodejs any web server and you know
anything you just show up and within
reason we can run it for a nice I spot
for your talk if I remember correctly
did you or maybe there was a different
talking and mixing things but I think
that you had someone else talking about
nodejs for companies yeah so that was
that was actually during the gcp next
talk and I had Joe McCain who's the CEO
of node source a company that does
Enterprise nodejs stage talking with us
there was there were some announcements
there maybe you should you could share
it with us yeah so the big thing that we
wanted to announce it next was just that
we formed a partnership with node source
and what that means is that we're able
to take the enterprise distribution of
nodejs that they've built and that they
support along with all the toiling in
their ecosystem and easily run that on
Google cloud platform so today really
what that means is it's a it's a
separate distribution of note that comes
with performance analysis tools and make
it easy to debug things like memory
leaks high cpu utilization produces
flame graphs a variety of great
visualization
to help dig in and really really
understand what's happening with no Jas
processes is they in the event they
start to run amok as on occasion they do
okay so I guess that means we've got
some stuff there with people can just
kind of get up with and just run with
from node source that they're able to
run on our platform just like they would
normally yeah absolutely all right now
most of the offering is centered around
compute engine but we're working really
hard to bring that to the other layers
of the stack down through container
engine and App Engine eventually as well
awesome so I'm actually quite curious as
well obviously you've had some
experience working with no developers
here on our platform what's the coolest
project you've seen of people building
stuff with note on on anything on google
cloud platform Wow anything on google
cloud platform with node with node well
other just to narrow it slightly other
than making a nobler cab turn see I
thought that was pretty much it
connecting it to little bits you know it
has everything right it's got IOT it's
got web sockets it's got node it's a it
was end-to-end on the platform well so
actually well backtrack for a sec e
we've talked a little about your
presentation for those people who
haven't seen is do you want to tell us
talk us through the demo you had and
then maybe we'll come back to original
question sure so it was just a couple of
some few demos some serious some just
for fun quite honestly because they
amused me but all of the idea of showing
off how to use nodejs on our platform so
first one we did was with the cloud
vision API we did a little analysis of
Reddit actually went on our / on we were
detecting images on reddit to figure out
if there were dogs or cats bring them in
the right category and kind of doing
real-time data analytics on stage that
one that was fun I was really really
worried when I was doing that demo the
reddit was going to go down there was
gonna be left standing there with an
empty web page but it all worked out and
then the other and then the last demo
that we started to put together was on
using little bits little bits or small
composable electronic building blocks
usually for kids or you know for the
young young at heart and they have this
thing called a cloud that lets you
connect him the internet so we started
playing around with those and seeing
what would be like to connect it to know
DJ s on Google cloud platform and you
know I think during during that there
was too much interference in the room
and not everything tied together the way
I would have liked but but it was still
pretty cool awesome and the final result
was a twirling a totally propeller on
your new
hat oh yeah it played music it twirl the
Hat it did everything it was a lots lots
of engineering manpower going into that
hat yeah definitely something that
definitely worth the effort that's great
ok cool so um all right this bunch of
work going into nodejs Google cloud
platform are you able to hint it
anything like what's up coming what
things should people expect you know
that sort of good stuff yeah absolutely
so phase one for us was kind of going
and making all this stuff run great on
Google cloud platform so we talked about
trace and debug and App Engine and and
the integration with node source and all
the fun stuff around that I think the
next step is actually integrating
ourselves more closely with no Jas as an
organization and as an underlying
technology so we've spent we've built up
all these years as i mentioned years of
muscle and making javascript work great
on the web browser well the next step is
actually digging and help make it run
better on the server i don't think that
we've done as much there as we've always
wanted to in the early days of node and
i think we could have a huge impact
doing things like making the developer
tooling and chrome work better with no
Jas make the debugging story a little
bit easier make the tooling story a
little bit better improve the
performance one of the things that we've
done to actually kick off this this next
stage of work now that we're past the
beta is we've actually just recently
joined the nodejs foundation and that's
a group that's responsible for driving
nodejs as a technology forward not just
on google cloud but making knowed better
for developers everywhere very cool that
that actually shows a lot of a lot of
commitment from google or we like being
being part of it really but what else
could people working for not yet working
with no Jas expect to see soon on Google
apart from we have a bunch of api's and
they can run on App Engine it's beta
clear tellers it'll be more about is
there any specific roadmap that you
could share your product manager so
maybe you have the power okay yeah
absolutely i think the biggest thing is
going to see from us moving forward a
better api support for all the cool
services so we announced a lot of great
stuff at gcp next things like cloud ml
the google cloud speech API as we start
to turn out more and more of these
services than we have to expose
meaningfully
p is for no developers not just on
google cloud platform but if you want to
take advantage these api's from your own
data centers from other clouds you know
we don't care however you want to do it
we want to kind of open up these sort of
i like to call them the the google cloud
magic api's all the stuff that does
machine learning we're gonna be spending
a lot of time they're improving those
api's and getting them in front of
everyone very cool we're pretty much out
of time but is there anything else that
you could like to mention that brilliant
have time to yeah the big thing is just
we we love JavaScript here at Google we
love the web we like connecting things
to the Internet and we like running
services and we're committed to making
Google Cloud the best place to run
nodejs applications and we're committing
committed to making nodejs itself better
so if you're looking for a place to
bring your code come to us that is
awesome well thank you so much Justin
for spending the time with us we really
appreciate it alright thanks a lot guys
this was fun thanks a lot cool thanks
again to Justin for such an awesome
conversation learned a lot I had lots of
fun we will have a bunch of links on the
show notes to all the legal resources
that he mentioned the tag where you can
see him wearing an ugly head that turns
around nice yep so it's lots of fun
before we finish for today let's talk
about the question of the week we said
it was big table but why don't you mark
tell us a little bit about the question
itself excellent so we got a nice email
from a gentleman by the name of Michael
Mackenzie his question is I think big
table could be used in one of my
personal projects but I do not know
where to start he's actually read the
Google paper on it good for him that's a
job well done however I find myself a
bit lost and fully understanding how to
get going that said do you have any
recommendations of simple apps or
projects one can get acquainted with big
table cool so I feel like this is kind
of like a two-parter actually I think
that the first part is when you say
you're planning and using it for
personal projects I could say think
about it twice unless your personal
projects have an amazing traffic and Nia
you really need throughput that I pent
up sorry that BigTable can offer I get
to them maybe their stories to play is
the place to be yeah I probably
most look at it as well from like
personal projects big table can be
expensive like yeah we turn around and
say yeah if you know you want a rather
large amount of data for that cost
savings down akhian if your personal
project requires something around like 1
million operations per second yes go for
it yes but if you're around one per
second probably picked a valise a little
bit overkill yeah probably but if you
actually want to learn more about big
table I think that read in the papers a
very very good step may be overkill to a
nice that's a very it's not probably the
best place to start if you want to
understand more but there's actually all
the documentation we also have a bunch
of a bunch of sample projects on github
so that's on github.com / google club
platform / cloud BigTable samples I
think but we will have will have the
links to those projects on the show
notes and in one of those examples you
could actually be able to see that
there's a tool called quick start in
quick there is a basically a Java tool
that allows you to use big table from
the from the command line so you can
create tables you can insert data you
can read from it so you can basically
get the little bit of an idea of how big
table actually works and then you can
start playing with it also it's cool
because if you have a lot of data you
can also see how incredibly fast it
works but if you're not a Java guy like
me and you think that maven is very hard
to understand which if you ask me it is
also xml come on but all right but
there's actually another tool that I
ended up using personally which is
called cbt that stands for cloud big
table and it's reading go so basically
you can just install it directly or we I
think that there's distribution bit
binary signer is for windows and mac and
linux and whatever and then you just run
it because you don't need anything else
because it's just a self maintained
binary so let's go not that you're
biased in any way shape or form
absolutely not yeah absolutely not okay
cool sir yeah if you want to get started
with big table like there's no reason
why you couldn't fire up a node and sort
of run it within the trial period feel
like I'm sure what period or something
like that three notes yeah 3 nodes yeah
that is the minimum but is the minimum
three nodes no that's totally true but
definitely shut that down again before
you're finished yeah yeah it's I mean I
think it's a very nice way to understand
the power of a cloud but at the same
time if it's for personal project
probably datastore it's a good place to
be yeah I guess if you're gonna be
running that long-term data store makes
a lot of sense if you're gonna do like a
few little bits and pieces you could run
it for a little bit and then turn it off
again cool well thank you so much mark
before we finish what are your plans for
next week next week next next week's
next week's I don't know if I actually
think I'm just gonna be hanging out in
San Francisco writing some content the
next few weeks very nice yeah about
yourself well I'm actually going to be
at the end of the month i will go to
Budapest my first I'm going they're very
excited to be talking about go craft
Gump very nice yeah we're gonna we're
gonna have some other people from the
from the advocacy team ya que hace
height i will be will be there also
talking about coburn at ease so I think
it's gonna be a very very good
conference excellent sounds like a lot
of fun brilliant well thank you so much
for joining me yet again friends ask I
really appreciate it thank you so much
for being here too and talk to you next
week see you next week
you